نحيي مشاهدينا الى هذا اليوم الثاني من
متابعه العربيه للانتخابات التشريعيه في
تونس انتخابات تحدث عنها الرئيس قيس سعيد
وقال بانها تاتي في اطار تصحيح المنظومه
كذلك قدما اجراءات استسائيه وهذه
الانتخابات تاتي ضمن هذه الاجراءات
الاستثنائيه ما اهميه هذه الانتخابات هل
هناك حديث عن قبل وما بعد نقف عند كل هذه
التفاصيل وتداعيات خاصه الارقام التي
سنحملها لضيوفنا لنناقشها خاصه ونتابع
تفاصيل المرحله القادمه ضيوفي اليوم
لمناقشات كل هذا معنى السيد خليفه
الشيباني المحلل السياسي اهلا بك كذلك
معنا السيد صغير الزكراوي استاذ القانون
العام بالجامعه التونسيه اهلا بك ومعنى
كذلك السيد وليد العباسي القيادي في
حزبئتين شعبي اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام سيد
خليفه نتحدث عن فاصل اثنين نسبه المقبلين
على التصويت وحضرتك من بينهم كذلك حدثنا
عن هذه التجربه وما الذي يمكن ان يمثله او
تمثله هذه النسبه التي وصفها البعض
بالنسبه المحدوده
كل انسان يجب ان يضرب صوته بصوته مع او ضد
او يحط ورقه بيضه هذه في الديمقراطيه ولو
انه في تونس
هو زاد اليوم
تاريخ الثوره التي قامت على اساس العداله
الاجتماعيه ولم تقوم على اساس مطالب
سياسيه معنا
القائمه الحزبيه
تبين هذه التجربه اليوم انه المالك سياسي
كان له دور كبير وان الاحزاب كانت لها
ماكينات سياسيه
هذه النسبه في حاجه الى تحرير في حاجه الى
قراءه لكن هناك زاد تاسيس الى مرحله جديده
مرحله بعد الانتخابات سيكون هناك مجلس
نواب في اعتقاده هو الحلقه الاخيره في
اطار مشروع 25 جويل هل ترك ضيفي بان هذه
الانتخابات ستؤسس لمرحله جديده فعليه على
المستوى السياسي على المستوى القانوني
وحضرتك خبير في القانون العام لما بدا
اهميه هذه الانتخابات في هذه الجزئيه
جميعا المقاييس هذه النسبه ضعيفه جدا حتى
لو وصلنا العشره
بالتوقيت
بالنسبه ضعيفه جدا بالنسبه ضعيفه لانه
السيد رئيس الجمهوريه يتحدث عن تاسيس
جمهوريه جديده
ويتحدث عن العلوم وشاهق ويتحدث عن
المشروعيه الذي يتمتع بها فاعتقد انه
ايوب سيكون ما قبل 17 وبعد 17 اعتقد ان
هذه النسبه ستضعف رئيس الجمهوريه الى بعد
الحدود تضعفه من ناحيه انه مشروع بل نقول
انا كنت من اول المسلمين
ولكن هذه نتيجه يعني التمشي الانفرادي كان
على سيد الرئيس ان يستشير في كتابه
الدستور وخاصه في القانون الانتخابيه وهذا
هل هذه النتيجه تعكس كذلك تمشي سيد رئيس
وتعكس همم النقائس الموجوده في القانون
الانتخابات وخاصه على مستوى التزكيات على
مستوى اقصى بعض الفئات فاعتقد انه سيكون
17 ديسمبر الذي اراد السيد الرئيس ان يكون
تاريخ الرمزيا يدعم مش رايته
من يوم الغد انه في موقف ضعيف داخليا
وخارجيا
تحدثت عن اقصاء همم اطراف همم ولكن كذلك
في مقابل هذا نتحدث عن احزاب قاطعت هذه
الانتخابات ولكن هناك احزاب بعض الاحزاب
التي همم شاركت في هذا الانتخابات ومن
بينها سيد وليد همم حزب تيار الشعبي همم
لماذا على عكس بقيت الاحزاب اخترتم ان
تشاركوا في هذه الانتخابات وما الذي
يمكننا تحميله لكم كحسبوا لي رؤيتكم كذلك
مثل هكذا الانتخابات سناتي بعد قليل على
تفاصيلها وعلى هذا المشروع ولكن في هذه
المرحله مل افاده التي تقدمها نحن نتقدم
بدايه الخيراتنا في مساء 25
اعتقدنا انه لحطه كالرسه فيها او مارس
فيها رئيس الجمهوريه اراده شعبيه في ايقاف
العبث في ايقاف التخريب في حق الدوله
التونسيه او كما قال احد الكتاب الكبار
المغاربه عبد الله هو انتفاضه الدوله على
حكومه وعلى مجموعه حاكمه يعني فاسده وتعبت
بال- بالدوله التونسيه يعني التيار الشع
حزب اصيل الوقت ليناتو موقف ما هوش معناها
ناس مرتبكين او مترددين او لذلك واضحه على
هذا النظام السياسي ان يرحل هذا النظام
السياسي الذي قد على مقاس مجموعه سياسيه
مخربه حركه النهضه ومجموعه من من انهبوا
ومن صادروا يعني مستقبل التونسي
حتى في فتره حساسه كهذا لم يعد له معنى
خاصه مع مقاطعه احزاب اخرى لا تتفق مع
حركه النهضه باي شيء
نحن في تقسيمه لمعارذي مسار 25 جويليه
نقسمها نصفين لا مجموعتين هناك من تضرر من
مسار 25 جوليا الناس هذه مصالحها ضربت لها
علاقاتها وغير ذلك لها نفود هناك يعني
مواطنين توانسه اخرين عندهم موقف اخر
عندهم فهم اخر وهذا حق وهم كاتونسيين
وحقهم التونسيين هذا ما فيش نقاش لكن احنا
اعتقد انه اذا اليوم فما مشاكل في علاقه
بانتخابات 17 ديسمبر فانا اعتقد انه نسبه
المشاركه هديه اذا كانت ضعيفه فانه جراء
ثلاثه حاجات واضحين وبيني اولا هو انه ملف
المحاسبه ما مشاش الى اخره وهدايا معناها
مشكله كبير بالنسبه التونسيين كانوا
يعتقدونه بعد 25 دقيقه كل ما نهبه مقدرات
وكل من شاركها في الاغتيال السياسيه كل من
معناها مورط في تسفير الشباب التونسي
التوتر كل من معناها فتحها الابواب لجهات
المالحه
هدايا
الموضوعيه معناها شعارات وما هي قيمه
احدث وابتديه المحاسبه هذه الباب الاول
الباب الثاني هو الوضع الاقتصادي
والاجتماعي لا يمكن ان تطلب التونسيين في
وضع اقتصادي وفي وضع اجتماعي صعب بالشكل
هذا والناس يعانوا الامرين اليوم انما
يكون مشاركين معناها بالشكل جيد في علاقه
في علاقه بالانتخابات
لم تكن في حجم لحظه 25 دقيقه
النقطه الثالثه والاخيره اللي هي في علاقه
بالمناخ بالمناخ السياسي قد يكونوا مشينا
بشكل جيد في التنظيم الدوله انه اليوم تم
توحيد السلطه التنفيذيه اليوم فما السلطه
التشريعيه وفم اليوم وظائف واضحه لكن
اعتقد انه كان في اعداد القانون انتخابي
لن اعطي مثالا في هذه في فتره الاستفتاء
نحن تمكنا ان احنا كحزب ان نعطي زخم
للاستفتاء هذه حملات تجاول في كام ربوع
الوطن لنعرف بهذا المشروع الدستور لكن في
علاقه بالانتخابات التشري نحن القانون لم
يسمح للاحذيه للشارك بالشركه جيدفع
مناضلاتنا ومناضلين وكان مكبلين في علاقه
بهديه كانت ثغره كبيره في علاقه بالقانون
الانتخابيه الباب الثاني في قانون
الانتخابي وهو التزكيات وقد عطل الكثير من
التونسيات والتونسيين في جمع التزكيات
وحتى الفتره ما كانتش فتره يعني بالشكل ده
بشكل جيد نحن اعتقد انه عوامل عده وصلنا
للموضوع بتاع النسبه النسبه ضعيفه دي فما
يجب على رئيس الجمهوريه الا ان يتلقى فارس
الشعب التونسي في جانب المريخ السياسي في
جانب ملف المحاسبه وفي الجانب الاقتصادي
والاجتماعي الشعب التونسي معاش قادر يصبر
على وضعه الاقتصاد والاجتماعي اليوم لابد
من التحرك وهذه الرساله واضحه ما زال فما
مرحله اخرى وهو الدور الثاني من
الانتخابات التشريعيه فلابد للدوله ان
تستفيد هذا الدور الثاني
لاننا تحدث عن برلمان بغرفتين براسين
يقولوا البعض نحن امام البرلمان وامام او
امام مجلس تشريعي وامام كذلك همم مجلس همم
كيف سيتم التطرق لها هل بالتكليف تعتقد
سيد خليفه هل بانتخابات اخرى ستفتح من
جديد مكاتب الاقتراع والبعض يقول بان هناك
حاله ملل انسحبت تعبير لانه همم منذ 2018
نحن مررنا بتقريبا خمس او ست انتخابات
متتاليه
في اعتقادهم وصلنا اليه اليوم هو خلينا هو
ساعه مشروع 25 جويليه قائم والوطنيين في
تونس وهم كثر وهمم مع المشروع
ماتش مع الاشخاص بالضروره احنا نحبه
من اي دوله
نقطه نقطه حتى لا تقدم كل همم
نعود 24
حفاضات عن المسار عندك موقف في المسار
احنا ما ليش راجعين العجين خاطر
ال 10 سمعتت التوانسه اما بالاغ
تيالين المعنويما اليوم التونسي جيع
ان اللي ما عنده حد شيء الكليه كل شيء
هذه او في هذا المسار النقاط ايجابيه يمكن
ان تخدم الازمه الاقتصاديه حاليا
مع الطبقه السياسيه
احنا اليوم ما هو ذكر ثوره تونسيه
قامت على اساس التونسيه
فقط تتابعين العرب ذكرى الثوره التونسيه
كما تحدث عنها السيد رئيس
احراق
يحتفل بها بتاريخ 14 جانفي وهو تاريخ خروج
من تعليم تونس
على شعبه التونسي
17 الشعب التونسي وصل لي ال 14
تونس عنده 25 سنه مش موجوده
الثوره التونسيه الشعبيه
مكرر كايخراج مقال عشان نحب الديمقراطيه
والاقاله نحب مجلس النواب منتخب قال نحب
اوضاعى و كرامتي ترجع لي في التشغيل وفي
بعد العشر سنوات وصلنا الى الدمار مشروع
قيس سعيد و25 جيجا لانه ق سعيده له قالوله
الوطنيه التونسي هو التقط اللحظه برده اما
حل البرلمان
والتعاسه سياسيه اللي خلقنا له والدمار
في حد حضرتك عن الكرامه وعن مطالبه تونسي
اليوم تبعت كاريكاتير في الواقعه استوقف
عني صوره موجود همم اعلى الصوره 2011
تونسي ينادي حريه كرامه عداله اجتماعيه في
2011 نادي حليب سكر مواد غذائيه همم
الموضوع الموضوع صعب همم
وهو راهم مطالب رئيس الجمهوريه
قوي
لما تفرد سيد الرئيس
ورفض المسار التشابه
انتهى مثلا 25 هو انت اليوم
ضربه قاتله للمسار الفردي
الاحادي للسيد الرئيس
كيف يمكن ان نفعل ذلك
بمراجعه الدستور بكتاب الدستور جديد ولكن
لا بد ان يسلك مسارا تشاركين لا يمكن
الاعاقه الواحد لشخص واحد ان يفكر الجميع
خاصه وان السيد الرئيس فك السيد الرئيس
يصدر من المرجعيه تقليديه وفوق بعدي في
محدود
رئيس الجمهوريه
اه صحيح محدود لانه ثقافه انا اتحدث عن
شخص اعرفه ما اعرف محدود
كل ما يريد لانه صور رئيس الجمهوريه رئيس
الجمهوريه وقوته في مستشريه في الفريق
الاعلامي في المشاهدين الاقتصاديين الى
غير ذلك اليوم سيد رئيس
في اي لحظه
بعد الاستشاره وكتابه الدستور وما فعله
السيد صادق بالعقيق
كنا ربما ان كذلك في القانون الانتخابي لم
يتذلك وهذه اخطاء
لم يحدث في التاريخ ان كتب رئيس الجمهوريه
دستور بنفسه ولا نفسه لماذا
السياسيه لم يحدث
نظام سياسي الكل فيه يحكم ولا احد لا يحكم
السيد الرئيس يحكم واحده فرعون فلاحيات
فرعونيه برنامج انا سؤالي الرئيسي اليوم
لماذا المنتخب الامان وليست له صلاحيات
هذا ما صار هذا فيه هذا سيد رئيس
ما يقوم به اليوم مش هو النزعه نزعه
تسلقيه انا افرض عليكم ما اريد افرد عليكم
مساري سنه ونص اللحظه التي دفعتيه حاله
الاستقلال تدوم سته اشهر فقط وليست سنه
ونصف سيد رئيس مسؤول عن كل هذا تداول يا
سوداء ومسؤولين عليها ولكن
يتحمل المسؤوليه ما بعد 25 يوليا
مسار يعني تمشي انفرادي احادي والذين
انخرطوا انه عيب على هذه الاحزاب وخسر
العروبيين انه منخرته في مساج لم يشاركوا
فيه
هل استشاركم السيد الرئيس في كتاب الدستور
هل استشاركم بكتابه القانون برشا
في علاقه بالمسار هذيك كل اللي كان نحطهم
لحظه مفصليه لحظه الاستشاره ولحظه الحوار
اللي صار فكان ارقى ارقى حوار يعني لاول
مره يصير حوار في البلاد في السابق كان
حواري يشارك فيه نبيل القروي واللي نرى
معناها ارشيف السيد هدايه وعلاقته بالقضاء
كان يشارك فيه يوسف الشهد كان يشارك فيه
مجموعات لها كلها معناها سجلات قضائيه
معناها خائبه برشلونه
بمعيه مجموعه من مكونات ومجموعه من
الشخصيه وراينا انفسنا في مشروع الدستور
ولذلك دعمنا مشروع دستور في 25 جوليا
وتنقلنا تقريبا الى كل شيء ودعنا هذا ما
فيش نقاش وقلنا انه راه في ما يتعلق حتى
بالها النت الموجوده فان هذا الدستور
مفتوح ما هو مش مغلق كما كان دستور 2014
كان الدستور توافقي كان دستور اتفاقات
وكان دستور مفاوضات بين البيج جراح البيج
قائد السبسي وحركه النهضه في باريس يعني
شوف العار دستور يكون معناها علاء انقاذ
جلسه في باريس هذاك قروش هذا له هذا عار
معناها على تويتر والتونسي لكن دستور يصوت
عليه تقريبا زوز منين و800 معناها تونسي
فان شكوا فيه هناك كله وانا اعتقد انه عبس
خلينا نعطيك الاساسي
ما اعتقد ان هذه محطه وهذه رساله شعبيه
واضحه ان هناك مشكله حقيقي في مسار 25
جويليه تعتبره منتهي كما يقول السيد صغير
جهه نجاحات والجهه يعني عثرات والفائده ان
احنا نستفيق على رئيس الجمهوريه ان يستفيق
ارسال الشعبيه في علاقه كما قلت في
البدايه الوضع الاقتصادي والوضع
الاجتماعيه باب المحاسبه والتنقيه المناخ
المناخ السياسيه واستكمال حتى بعض من
التعيينات في لانه تم ادارات اليوم في
تونس والثمن مسؤوليات ما هي معناها ما هي
شدتها ناس تتحمل مسؤوليتها لذلك على على
رئيس الجمهوريه ان يفتح بابه وينصطا بشكل
جيد لان نحن في الحزب التيار الشعبي
مطلبناش لقاءه في ولا مره مطلبنا لقاء
ولكن كنا نتوجه لشعبنا لانه نعتبروا انه
هو الاساس ما قيس سعيد الا جزء من مسار 25
يولي مش كله لكن فمن يسوقه تعتبر
هم او لن يستاقطون انفسهم قبل كل شيء لكن
احنا كحزبه شعب نعتبر وانفسنا شركاء في 25
جويليه وما رئيس رئيس جمهوريه الشركه همم
سيد خليفه هل هذا المسار نتحدث على مسار
25 جويلي على الاجراءات الاستثنائيه وعلى
تصحيح الطريق كما تحدث السيد رئيس يقول في
بانه هذه الانتخابات هي الدليل نهايه هذا
المسار
لا هو الانتخابات ال 50% 140% في تونس ما
عندها حتى معنى كلمه اوضاع الاجتماعيه
والاقتصاديه للناس تكون ب 10% ولا تكون
اليوم 50% المنجز الاقتصادي والاجتماعي هو
اللي يحدد المسار السياسي في تونس عليها
بالتالي النسبه يلزم يلتقطتها الرسائل
رئيس الجمهوريه لكن حتى كان كانت اليوم 40
ولا كانت تقبل للانتخابات
ماذا يقول عنه البعض بانه برلمان سحبت منه
كل صلاحياته
لو سمحت
عندهم صلاح
التونسي سابق يعني معره بخصوص لمده فيه
بلاصه في العالم لا تطلب بطاقه السواق
العدليه
ولا مستوى التعليم الابتدائي
هناك ديمقراطيه بدات تونس ستوكرز لها
وتؤسس لها عشر سنوات مرت من عمر التونسيين
للتاسيس لشيء معين
الديمقراطيه في علم السياسه وانا درستها
هي اتخذتها شعوب لتحسين اوضاعها
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه الديمقراطيه
انتخابات لا معنى لها فلتذهب
يفهموا الناس اليوم يقارنوا بفتره بن علي
الناس اليوم تشوف الاسعار هي اللي قاعده
محروقه في المكان مش ابوه هذا هو الخطاب
اليوم شعب التونسي يقول اني كان جاي مستمد
هذا احنا عايشين في الشارع
مليش مسكر على روحها مكاتب ومش عايشه بين
شعب تونس حقيقي لا لا لانه السيد رئيس جاء
بخطاب همم يعتبر انهو جديد وقال انا
لمقاربه جديده ولي تفكير جديد وسيد رئيسين
لا يؤمن بديمقراطيه فلفليه ولا يؤمن
بالانتخابات
قال بانه همم برلمان من غرفتين وكاننا
امام همم مجلس عموم مجلس الاوردات الاول
همم تشريعي والثاني تمثيلي فهل هذا
النموذج يتقارب او هذه مقاربه يمكن ان
تكون دقيقه هذا النموذج
همم مجلس الجهات والاقاليم تمثيلي والمجلس
الثاني تشريعي له سلطه همم بنسبه معينه
ولكن همم يمكن ان همم يراقبها الرئيس الى
النظام السياسي هندسه النظام السياسي كلها
خاطئه
الهندسه النظام السياسي كيفما بني رئيس
جمهوريه استاثر بجميع صلاحيات
وترك بعض الفتات لمجلس نواب وبعد صلاحيات
لي مجلس يعني المجلس الجهات والاقليم يعني
صلاحيات الهامه الكل يتمتع بها رئيس
الجمهوريه وهذا النظام نراه نظامنا له
نظام رئاسي وله نظام برلماني هو نظام
يحلنا الى نوع من نظام الامامه
التقليديه لانه ما سماش رئيس جمهوريه
معصوم من الخطا وليست له مسؤوليه وهذا
الخطا الكبير لا يمكن ان يؤسس لجمهوريه
جديده
ولمجتمعها جديد بها ثلاث دستور وبهاك
الانتخابات هذا مسار عبى فيه هذه مغامره
السيد الرئيس
ان ان اتحدث بهذا بنوع من الالم ولكن لا
نعتبر السيد رئيس الجمهوريه هذا لحظه لن
تتكرر لا انا معه السيد خليفه لما شخص
مثلا يعني برلمان النصوص والمهربين احنا
قلت هذا لو قلت له نظام يعني التشخيص
لانه سيد رئيس الجمهوريه يجلس مع الجميع
هو مغامره الشخصيه السيده رئيس رسمه بنفسه
لم يشرك فيه اي ترفض كيف تعلق سيد خليفه
وانت مؤيد لكل هذا المسار
بانتخاباته وبكل اجراءاته الاستثنائيه
لينتقي الى بناء من عشريه لا امل فيها الى
امل الاخر يقول لك عبسي هو تحت التقييمه
هو تحليله هو انا في كل الحالات اعتبره
انا لوس الاسود
في الاستشاره الوطني
اليوم معادش عندهم في السياسه حتى شيء انا
قلت لك تونسي
اليوم التوانسه لو الجسم فما دراسات 67%
من التونسيين راغبين في المغادره البلاد
اليوم التونسي بيزيد يتكلم ويحكي لك على
وضعه
اجتماعي خليفه
هو خبزهم واا قوتهم اليوم وحياتهم اليوميه
وفي
الحكومه من عينها عندها سنه ونصف تقريبا
هينها سيد رئيس الجمهوريه
وادابات الكارثين حتى من الاحزاب التي
تسنى السيد الرئيس عندها تحفظ وطنيه
بتغيير الحكومه لان المفروض كان للسيد
الرئيس بهم كانوا ان يحاول الناس ليس
بمايته انتخابيه وان بين مشروعيه
الانجازات الا غير موجود للاسف كان سيد
الرئيس سنه ونصف كان بامكانه ان يلتقط بعض
الاصوات ونلتقط بعض يعني حتى هذه الاحزاب
لم تطلب لقاء السيد الرئيس وكانه هناك عبر
الاعلام
الاستاذ وليد يقول لم نطلب مقابله الرئيس
لطرح مشروع معين وهنا اللون كذلك يمكن ان
يقع على هذه الاحزاب هو
المشكله الكبيره هو ما حاولت اغتسال
اختزال 25 في قيس اعداد المشكله كبيره فما
حتى الناس في توصيفها يعني تحاول ان شخصا
في العمليه وكانه فما بعض السياسيين بعض
من رموز السياسيه في البلاد كان يتمنى انه
هو من قام بهذا الاجراء لكن التاريخ هناك
رئيس جمهوريه هو من اخذ بزمام الامور
ومارس يعني ما طلبه منه التونسي ثم بعض من
الشخصيات تعتقد اللي هي كانت ربما كان
لابد ان تح
ظى باحدى في لحظه من لحظات لكن لم يتم ذلك
فكان عندها توجهها اخر وكان عنده توصيل
لكن نحن حزب سياسي انا مسؤوليه سياسيه
قدام شعبنا قدام التاريخ وجامد بلادنا
نتوجه الى عام الناس الى شعبنا توجهنا الى
شعبنا فقلنا ان هذا النظام السياسي يقصد
نظام السياسي مقبل 25 نظام منهجيد نظام
اشبههم بنظام الطائفي نظام في العراق
بثلاث رؤوس حاله اشتباه كبرى ما بين
السلطه التنفيذيه اللي هي براسين
فلا بد من توحيد السلطه التنفيذيه وان
يكون امام التونسيه مسؤول واحد نحاسبه في
الانتخابات
لا بد ان يقف العبث في علاقه مجلس النواب
لان النواب يشترون يعني في الغرف المظلمه
الشعب التونسي يستخاره
اللي موجوده
لاعطاء فرصه كذلك للنائب همم لن ندخل في
دوامه همم اعطيت وكاله سحبت الوكاله قعدت
تنصيب همم هذا سيطل المسار في علاقه في
علاقه بين ماخذ النظام السابق النظام
السابق كان الشعب التونسي يتم الاختيار ثم
يجمد لمده خمس سنوات ويترك التشريع يعني
صاحب التشريع صاحب السلطه يعطي التشريع
لنواب وثم يتجمد لمده خمس سنوات حتى يرحم
ربي جل الانتخابات بعد خمس سنوات فقلنا
هديه لابد ان ينتهي وهذه ما جاء في
الدستور ثم الاستفتاء تم تسهيله كان من
شبه المستحيلات في عهد في الدستور السابق
بتاع 2014
في سنه 2022 بهذا الشباب لتولد ب 2010 وحل
عينيها على الثوره وحل عينيها على
الديمقراطيه وغيره ما هواش ممكن توجه نحو
الاستبداد غيره حاجه اخرى اخيرا اختبارها
تم هاوس بالانتخابات وبديمقراطيه المعلبه
بتعلم الامريكان وبتاع الاوروبيين الفائده
في الاصوات تم تعدديه فما غيره لكن دون
نتائج فنحن اعتقد انا الديمقراطيه
الحقيقيه هي ما شاهدناها اليوم في
الانتخابات
منجه من معلمين من الفلاحين من صناعيين
اليوم يتوجهون بس هو يمثلوا شعبهم في غيره
سابقا كان موجود
المهربين ومجموعه من المحامين ورجال
الاعمال وكذا وغيره وقله قليلا من يمثل
يعني
موجود بالعوده الى النتيجه
ااا لقناه العربيه الهيئه الانتخابات تعلن
بانه الى حدود الساعه السادسه نتائج
الانتخابات الاوليه هي بنسبه مشاركه 8.8%
همم 8.8% ايوه يعني لم نتخطى حتى حاجز
التسعه لم نصل الى حدود 10% يعني شوف معي
اقرا معي استخلاف وساعود لك همم
في حدود الساعه الثالثه
الانتخابات تتحدث عن سبعه فاصل 19% خلينا
نقول 7.00 سنه بعدها بثلاث ساعات وصلنا
لحدوث ثمانيه فاصل ثمانيه بالمئه ليس هناك
همم يعني اقبال مهم رفع من هذه النسبه
لا هو هو خلينا نشوفه معناها ايه هي نسبه
ضعيفه ما فيهاش حتى ما فيهاش حتى تفسير
ليه كده لازم تفهم باللي انتخابات الثاني
تختلف عن كل الانتخابات اللي عرفتها تونس
معناها سواء 2011 ولا بعد 2011 هذه
انتخابات ما فيهاش تمويل عموم هذه
انتخابات تقوم على الافراد هذه انتخابات
تقوم علاء من انظف الانتخابات اللي تم
خليك نقول معناها تبين زاد الانتخابات
السابقه اللي هي زاد وصلنا فيها 25 وغيرها
و30 في وقت الاحزاب موجوده اللي راح يزداد
العمليه الانتخابيه في تونس في حاجه الى
مراجعه معنا الانتخاب كانت ماكينات وكلنا
في تونس عارفين وهذا ما غادي يعمل في عمله
اخرى في السلوك الانتخابي بتاع تونسي
من انتخابات الى اخرى في تونس
اليوم اقتنع انه اذا كان السياسه
مده طويله ما تغيرلوش اوضاعه فلتذهب الى
الجحيم
يبدو انها نسبه النهائيه في كل الحاجات
اللي انت تتزوج العشره بالمئه اكيد
انتخابات تتحدث عن اسباني
اعتقلها لا تتحول الى حاجه من حبش نقولها
ولكن للاسف انها مهزله
واصبحنا وسبح وضحوكه العالم لانه صيد
الرئيس روى رفع من نسبه العلوم والشاق
بتاعه والتاسيس لجمهوريه جديده وقيم جديده
فلنتفاعل مع الاخوه الضيوف بتاع الكل رئيس
الجمهوريه
نازعه نحو التسلط نازل نحو التسلط وبرزت
في بعض المراسيم المراسيم اربعه
ان لا يمكن نحكي معك ما عادش نحكي كلمه
قبل اربع خمس اشهر نحكي خايف من المرسومه
غير ربما اتلفظ واخرج عنها
ربما حتى تتكلم خارج الاطار شويه وكذا يقع
همم استدعاء همم
ثم نزع نحو التصلب المساله ثانيه رئيس
لا يتحمل المسؤوليه يقول لك هذا النظام
تحمل فيه رئيس الجمهوريه ونعرف ليه رئيس
الجمهوريه قال انا نحكم لكن ما نيش مسؤول
حتى علشان لا برلماني نجم سالني ولا اي
جهه طالبه انا لقب انا ما عندي ما عندي
حكم مسؤوليه لانه يتصور نفسه انه ايمان
وانه معصوم من الخطا ثم موجوده
حتى نظام رئاسه
لكنه عليه
الهندسه الكل يعني نظام سياسي
القانون الانتخابي والمسار ككل المسار انا
اقول
ومسار عاد في قادنا الى ذلك قادر الى هذا
واعتبر انه بالنسبه
انتهت مغامره
دقيقه
يرى بانه نحن اعزمون على او تونس قادمه
على ضمن نهائيه اسوا وافضل السيناريوهات
همم التي تراها افضل السيناريوهات هو على
رئاسه الجمهوريه انها تتحمل مسؤوليتها
وانت تلقى احسن السيناريوات ان تتلقى
رساله الشعب التونسي
اعتقد انه سيكون لنا مجلس نواب نوع ما
مضغوط ضعيف وشعبين سيكون ضعيف وعليه
مسؤوليتك كبرى وهذا ما يضاعف يعني
هتكون في 25 بعد 25 واهداف 25 تحسين اوضاع
تونس اذا ما تحسنش اوضاع تونس ما عندي حتى
تدلل في علاقه بالامامه الاماميه ولا
الامام الاثنى عشريه ههه
والتوصيف قانوني نعطيه يعني لا لا لا وقت
اللي يسمى مجلس النواب يعني ليس بدون صلاح
نعم نعم
السيد خليفه
استاذ القانون العام بالجامعه تونسيه
السيد وليد العباسي القياسي في حسب التيار
الشعبي شكرا جزيلا لكم